this is what heaven is like and things
just got a little too real it's episode
38 of IMG okay so this is Katy Perry and
this is Paula Deen uh-oh
because this is Tom Hanks and this is 50
cent coincidence here's a caterpillar
whose pattern resembles little penguins
and what if Obama was a white guy
crystal emailed me a picture she took of
a cooler lid that says wow look at them
jugs but on to dessert freak girl makes
beautiful cupcakes but the pun award
goes to her up cakes parents can be
scary but this picture is one of the
most terrifying I've ever seen can you
make sense of this shape what is it and
in these next two pictures can you find
the faces and that's right you guessed
it it is now time for 99 pictures of
bananas enjoy them all
[Music]
here's an artist who meticulously cuts
paper with an exacto blade to make
swirling portraits out of a single sheet
and here is a giraffe licking a squirrel
how about a panda on a rocking horse or
face paint of famous paintings Warhol
Pollock the screen Magritte starry night
Pocky box delivers realistic South Park
families and Mario delivers any
performance enhancing drug you want
because now you're swimming with portals
hello oh baby hands are delicious but
after the town of Coleman Scapa Namibia
was abandoned wind and sand reclaimed
the homes leaving these eerie desert
rooms also eerie our underground
neutrino detectors eerie and very very
large you can like us on Facebook to
show off your exceptional taste and as
always thanks for watching